we have is to provide a facility
where manufacturers from low and
middle-income countries can receive
training in how to produce certain
vaccines
and the licenses to do so
we believe the marine technology
transfer hub holds huge promise
not just for increasing access to
vaccines against scorpio 19
but also for other diseases including
malaria tuberculosis
and
cancer i was honored to have the
opportunity to visit the hub two weeks
ago
and it's already producing results with
african's announcement that it has
produced its own mrna vaccine
candidate producing mrna vaccines poses
some barriers to low and middle-income
countries
including their costs the fact that they
require a cold chain that's difficult
and expensive to implement
it also requires a skilled
and trained
workforce
currently
by manufacturing training facilities are
located mainly in high-income countries
and operate on a free fee based system
putting them out of reach for many
lower income countries
that's why today
double joe
the republic of korea and the wh academy
are announcing the establishment of a
global my biomanufacturing training hub
that will serve low and middle-income
countries that wish to produce not just
vaccines
but other biologics including insulin
and monoclonal antibodies
the government of the republic of korea
has offered a huge facility that
conducts
by manufacturing training locally
and will expand its operations
to accommodate trainees from other
countries
the wh academy will support these
efforts by helping to develop a
comprehensive curriculum on
biomanufacturing
the first two countries to join the mrna
technology transfer hub last year were
argentina and brazil
companies from both countries are
already receiving training
last week we announced the first six
african countries that will receive
technology to produce their own mrna
vaccines
egypt kenya nigeria senegal south africa
and tunisia
today we are announcing a further five
bangladesh indonesia pakistan serbia and
vietnam
that brings the total so far to certain
and we're in discussion with several
other countries
we're honored to be joined today by four
countries that are now participating in
the hub
and we'll start receiving training from
next month
but first it's my honor to welcome
his excellency dr khon deok
the minister of health and welfare of
the republic of korea mr khan welcome
and thank you so much for your
government support for this very
exciting new initiative and you have the
floor
mr kwan we think you're muted can you
unmute yourself
[Music]
okay
now begin again
dear excellencies and colleagues
it is a great honor for korea to be
nominated as the wh global
biomanufacturing workforce training hub
with a sense of excitement
what this means
to fulfill
this important role with the sense of
duty
i convey
my deepest sense of gratitude to who
together with the who and the
international community
korea will no airport in training
personnel from low and middle-income
countries
to build and strengthen their own
infection and biologics manufacturing
capabilities
for korea to be nominated as the global
bio manufacturing workforce training hub
holds particular significance
just 60 years ago korea was one of the
first countries in the world
for decades
the impoverished
and weak public health system used to be
one of the biggest problems that the
korean government had to serve
with the help and support of the who
and the international community
korea has transitioned
into a country with a strong public
health system
and a country that exports medical
essentials such as infections and
biologics
creatively cherishes the solidarity
that the international community has
shown us during our transition
now korea is ready to stand in
solidarity with lm isis to share our
experience
starting in july this year korea plans
to train 370 professionals from africa
asia and south america
in the field of perfection and biologics
and we plan to accommodate more trainees
in the future
korea will strive to support all in
strengthening their capabilities to
manufacturing vaccines
the continuing challenge
with the chronovirus epidemic humbly
reminds us of
the critical needs for nations to
collaborate and to stand in solidarity
with one another in order to overcome
this global crisis of public health
system
by sharing the lessons korea has learned
from our own experience in the past
korea will strive
to support the lmiss
in strengthening their biomanufacturing
capabilities
so that we could pay our way together
towards the safer world
during the next endemic
korea looks forward to you all
for your continued support and interest
thank you
thank you once again for the republic of
korea's generosity
in supporting this effort
and now the four countries that will
receive vaccine technology from south
african hub and receive training to
produce it
we begin in who's southeast asia region
with indonesia it's my greater pleasure
my great pleasure
to welcome her excellency retro marsudi
retinol marsudi the minister of foreign
affairs of in indonesia
mr marsudi thank you for joining us
today and welcome and you have the floor
shri makase
well thank you very much digital's
colleagues ladies and gentlemen it is an
honor for me to be back in geneva and
have meetings with tj tedros
kev gaffy and convex and i'm very glad
to participate in this press conference
before flying back to jakarta colleagues
indonesia is one of the countries that
continuously support vaccine equity
including through transfer of vaccine
technology and know-how to developing
countries
indonesia's
g20 presidency also includes this issue
as one of the priorities
today i'm very pleased to hear that
indonesia and biopharma have been
trusted to be one of the beneficiaries
for the mrna vaccine technology transfer
biopharma is the largest vaccine
manufacturer in southeast asia with
production capacity of more than
3.2 billion doses per year
it produced 14 types of vaccine and has
exported to more than
150 countries
indonesia's ability to harness the mrna
technology will serve the regional's
need
for the mrna technology driven vaccine
and therapeutic development and
manufacturing
this transfer of technology will
certainly
contribute to equal access to health
countermeasures those helping us recover
together and recover stronger
this is the kind of solution that
developing countries need
a solution that empowers
a solution that strengthens our
self-reliance a solution that allows us
to contribute to global health
resilience
colleagues
this kind of cooperation needs support
from all of us and we do hope that this
cooperation could narrow vaccine
inequality
our time is short that is why our work
to end this pandemic needs to be
effective
so the benefit of our collaboration
becomes infinite together we show
multilateralism delivers and brings
benefit to our people recover together
recover stronger i thank you
recover together recover stronger i
fully agree
minister retinol and trimakase
and we look forward to continuing to
support indonesia on this journey and so
that indonesia can support the world so
trimacas and thank you so much for
joining us in person that's a great
honor
and i understand
you have other commitments so thank you
so much for joining us today and
safe travel back back home
shifting now to the americas it's now my
honor to welcome dr carla visotti the
minister of health of argentina
your excellency welcome and you have uh
the floor
foreign
disease related
challenges accordingly
it's a pleasure for me
to join you today virtually
to
share
this
important announcement about
recipients in other parts of the world i
would also like to congratulate them
we're happy to be working together
as an enormous challenge we're convinced
of the decisive role
that a diversified pharmaceutical
manufacturing capacity has to promote
equitable access
to
um
south america is the region in the world
that has one of the highest levels of
vaccine coverages coverage and in the
region of the americas
argentina
has received
over 110 million doses of vaccine and
we've managed to reach almost 80 percent
vaccine vaccination
and we've coverage
surpassed the objective set by the who
before during this year that's halfway
through this year
in our country we've managed to provide
over 48 million birth doses
and
60 million
booster doses we've also received almost
100 million doses all over the country
and we've also provided
five media doses to other regions and
continents around the world
and it's very important to create this
virtuous circle and provide solidarity
to make progress on vaccinations
as a result of our vaccination campaign
campaign in our country
which which has been carried out over
three years
to improve the epidemiological situation
and continue working on other
areas related to health strategies
colleagues latin america
accounts it does have the necessary
capacity to improve local production and
increase access to vaccines it also has
strategic inputs of other types and it's
very important to
show how other countries
regions of the world can help to
contribute towards achieving global
challenges
the public sector and
the health sector in argentina are very
ready to overcome these challenges and
of course we're very happy to have the
technical support for the wh
and particularly with regards to the
regional offices
we've also got the international experts
future health emergencies
to make sure that we can
break
the current cycles that are in place
and promote equitable distribution
distribution of these products thank you
very much and i'm pleased to be working
with you
now to europe and it's my privilege to
welcome dr
la tibor longer the minister of health
of serbia your excellency thank you for
joining us today
welcome and you have the floor
uh
their colleagues dear representatives of
the media the republic of serbia has
expressed interest
in participating in the project uh who
project the dealing with the transfer of
mrna vaccine production technology the
efficiency and flexibility of the
serbian system demonstrated in the
previous period through chrome
diagnostics prevention treatment
distribution of vaccines medication and
medical devices have proved
as sufficient and requisite precondition
to continue with further development in
this domain by participating in this
project national production capacity
will be established aiming at improved
access to vaccines produced through the
application of the most modern
technologies contributing as well to the
overall increased readiness for the
potential pandemic response
by forming the regional center so-called
mrna hub in the republic of serbia we
will be able to fulfill the requirements
of both national and international
health systems
the support of the world health
organization
in this process is of essential
importance for the development of
continuing safe and modern production
vaccines the development of new
technology implies the development of
professional knowledge of serbian
experts in training of new young staff
as the absolute national priority
during the pandemic we have learned that
introducing new technologies into
research and making decisions based on
evidence and
are the most essential factor for
effective response to all public health
threats
i would like to conclude by expressing
gratitude to the world health
organization for con its continuous
support since i'm convinced that we
shall continue uh with excellent
cooperation this area as well as other
public health areas my best wishes from
belgrade and i'm looking forward to
meeting you soon in person here in
belgrade thank you
your excellency thank you once again for
being with us today
finally to the western pacific where
it's my great pleasure to welcome his
excellency dr muya time long the
minister of health of vietnam
your excellency thank you for joining us
today and for vietnam's participation in
this exciting new initiative you have
the floor
dear ladies and gentlemen
first of all i would like to control
date of mutual and mna vaccine
technology transfer help
on the
historic achievement made in the last
couple of months
including the suggestion of beneficiary
country
of the mni vaccine technology transfer
the establishment of the global bio
manufacturer
bringing workforce
training herb in the republic korea
which is also announced today
i also recognize that the mpp and the
ict confucking partner is the
initiative
on behalf of the government of people in
vietnam
i'm very glad to expand our sense of
thank you that future for selecting
vietnam to receive the mna vaccine
technology technology due to that
neutral mna vast integrity transfer
initiative
this shows up that nature highly
when you have a capacity to master the
technology and produce a vaccine in
smart scan is the high quality
the government of misophone of vietnam
are committed to supporting and creating
favorable
condition for domestic vaccine very
culture
in receiving the eminent vaccine
technology
as you may know that we have had a lot
of experience in vaccine development
over the plastic
our nai and ar
has also been recognized by the nature
we believe that in participating in
initiative vietnam will produce many
vaccines not only for domestic
consumption
but also for the other countries in the
region and the world contributing to
reducing
inequality
in asset to vaccine
the mni vaccine technology is an in
advanced technology that allows
affecting the vaccine to adapt to new
the variant more easily and be produced
in last
quantity
develop breaking technology not only
help control the corporate lighting
pendant but also better respond to
future appendage therefore when i'm
hoped to continue receiving some
platforms
to connect our regular mutual and
partner to go one step further in this
initiative thereby contributing to
centennial production capacity of boxing
in the vision contributing to activity
to ensure international and regional
health security and thank you very much
shin come on minister muyan and thank
you once again to you
to all our guests for joining us today
we look forward to working with all of
you in the months and years ahead
our vision is that this initiative
will pay dividends for many years to
come and help to save
many lives because we believe it's a
strategic solution to the problem of
equity we're facing now
margaret back to you
thank you very much dr ted ross and
distinguished panel
we will now open the floor to questions
from the media
please try to focus your questions on
the subject technology transfer and
training but we do have our usual team
of wh experts here to ensure you get the
best and most complete answers
we also have uh dr anjes buzan
our executive director of who academy
who can tell you more about how who will
be supporting the curriculum for the
bio manufacturing training
uh first question
goes to donato mancini from the
financial times donato could you
unmute yourself and ask your question
hi good morning good afternoon thank you
so much for the opportunity i have two
questions for you so
i understand this may be difficult at
the stage but can you quantify the
impact this will have concretely um with
any numbers if that's possible
um
such as you know this will help make xx
million doses of vaccine or xx million
biles of insulin obviously i understand
why this is good news and big news but
i think it would help to provide context
to our readers
and the second question is um
critics will say this is great but
perhaps a bit late so
did you try to do this earlier in the
pandemic and did you face resistance
from certain sectors such as the
industry thank you very much
thank you genato i think dr sumio will
start and others may join
thank you donato um for that question
others may certainly
like to add
so as you remember right from the
beginning of the pandemic the who had
recognized that the vaccine inequity or
inequity and access to health products
in general
is a real threat and a real possibility
that we needed to
get ahead of and this is why
the act accelerator and the kovacs
facility and partnership was created
specifically to address the issue of
vaccine inequity
however because of the
fact that vaccines
and in fact other health products the
manufacturing of these products is
concentrated in some regions of the
world
what we saw happening was that other
regions of the world which did not
manufacture
products actually got to the into the
back of the queue and they had to wait
uh
till the regions that were manufacturing
had actually supplied their own
populations and then were able to spare
doses
and we made a call very early on if you
remember the the dg
had called for the um
for the uh motion at the wto on the
trips waiver
to go ahead that countries would should
agree to do that we had also called upon
companies to share their
know-how technology either through
voluntary licensing
or through these multilateral mechanisms
that exist we have the medicines patent
pool that does exactly that and has
happened with some drugs but we have not
seen that happen with uh with vaccines
except for a couple of companies that
did go out and do a lot of voluntary
licensing but and we saw clearly that it
wasn't enough in the whole of 2021
we were facing the supply constrained
situation where countries were unable to
scale up their vaccination programs
because of unpredictable supplies
and often supplies that came with short
expiry dates
so this concept was launched
in april of last year
and i think has moved fairly rapidly but
of course it's it's complex it requires
uh not only developing and transferring
a new technology but it also requires a
building of facilities that can handle
this type of expertise and training
people to do this so we're looking at
this as a medium to long term
initiative
not
as you said
necessarily solving the problems in 2022
we know the pandemic hasn't ended we
know that there may be ongoing demand
for vaccines so this project may still
satisfy the demand in the future and
make perhaps a better vaccines
with better properties available
as we move ahead as you know one of the
things we are trying to do here is to
promote more r d and sharing of
information and knowledge by with these
networks of
of centers that are going to be set up
uh because mrna technology is new and
currently comes with a lot of
limitations and usage especially the
cold storage conditions so the so
there could be game changing
technologies in the pipeline where mrna
could be stored at four to eight degrees
for example and also be more made in
ways that
make it more affordable to produce these
vaccines and finally i think this
technology and this whole process of
empowering and building capacity
in places around the world will not only
enable
more work on vaccines of other public
health importance like tb like dengue
like chikungunya and other diseases
but also serve
you know as our
backup plan for the next pandemic so
that
if and let's hope there isn't but if
there is another pandemic with another
pathogen there will be all of these
distributed manufacturing sites that are
capable
of absorbing and quickly scaling up mrna
so that in any one lab in the world
were to develop a vaccine for that new
pathogen
then within a few
weeks or months we could have capacity
we could have manufacturing scaling up
very rapidly
and so i think that really is the goal
with which
we we approached this not necessarily to
solve the problem of today
which needs to be solved basically by
equitable sharing of vaccines and making
sure that
we address also some of the absorption
constraints the delivery constraints
that countries are facing
thank you i wonder if anyone would like
to add to that
dr mariangela uh
shamal who's online has something to add
on this
over to you
thank you very much margaret i think you
do not too far for the question actually
i want to touch on the biomanufacturing
hub
and the importance it has uh we don't
have yet to quantify the issue on
diabetes like you you mentioned but let
me say that by manufacturing hub
in korea the republic of korea is
especially important for us to deal with
problems that are beyond cohabit right
and also let me talk about a little bit
about the
the issue that we did we were talking
about the biotherapeutics
right for cause it we did speak with
each of the manufacturer of the bacteria
because you know there are some of them
already in in dubli joe's guidelines and
there's always an issue that's mentioned
when you're talking about id or
technology transfer there's always the
issue of all but the quality
manufacturing capacity is not available
elsewhere so let me say that the
biomanufacturing hub
as a training hub working with the
regulatory and the
uh
the good practices in the manufacturing
and being in korea will be extremely
helpful for double jewel in the world to
tackle
chronic diseases like diabetes there is
an increasing
need for monoclonal antibodies for
example for cancer treatment for
immune diseases and so on so we are
talking about causes but we are talking
also beyond voting and no we did we did
yes we did talk with the manufacturers
the current manufacturers you know there
was no interest in tech transfer so
that's why
this has been
been
organized now and has a significant
importance for the future only access to
affordable and safe treatments thank you
dr buzan would you like to add anything
on the importance of training and the
difference this is going to make
yes
thank you very much um first of all we
are really looking forward to work with
the korean
global biomanufacturing workforce
training hub because we think that there
is some place for in-person training but
also for hybrid experience with digital
training to and enhance
the capacity building of healthcare
workforce to deal with those issues of
biomanufacturing
the role of the wh academy in this
hub
will be of course to to
establish the entry requirements
for the learners to to
define the curriculum pathway to be able
to deal with those issues and of course
to give assessment and credentials to
the learners
to be sure that they
gain some new skills new competencies
to
ensure good quality biological products
at the end so
we are really willing for this
collaboration thank you
thank you so much for all those
comprehensive answers uh the next
question goes to preeti patnayak from
geneva health files preeti and mute
yourself and ask your question
uh good afternoon uh thanks for taking
my question um can you clarify
whether and when
other companies in other asian countries
including say chinese and indian
companies will be able to participate in
regional manufacturing activities around
mrna vaccines
because clearly these countries do have
you know early infrastructure to produce
these vaccines
because it was previously indicated that
some exceptions could be made while
issuing licensing from the hub to
exclude potentially big developing
countries uh can you clarify if that's
the case thank you
thank you pretty dr martin frieda will
answer your question okay thank you
pretty a very good question um
what we are trying to avoid is to have
excessive competition within countries
or to be leading to excessive
competition
and so countries such as india and china
which have already
a they've got some
mrna vaccine candidates already under
development
and also we received multiple requests
from within those countries so we are
currently working with the national
government to identify what they would
like us to be supporting uh within the
country but these this will still take
some time as we as we work out
what is the most appropriate
response for each country thank you
thank you dr freda i'm looking around
the room i think that's fully answered
that question
so the next question goes to
uh
andy hoffman of bloomberg andy please
unmute yourself and ask your question
uh thank you good afternoon thanks for
taking my question um just so i
understand that um focusing on uh covet
19 mrna vaccines
the
the the vaccines that will be produced
um under this program are the ones that
you're developing from the mrna
uh
hub in south africa how long will it
take
for that formula to be developed
so it will be ready to be a vaccine and
then be approved
by various health authorities including
the who
as a vaccine
and have you completely abandoned
working with and getting um
technology transfer from the other the
major mrna vaccine
producers pfizer and moderna
thank you
thank you very much this is dr sumiya
swaminathan will start the answer on
this one
yes i'll start i'm sure martin would
like to add as well
so
to
the first i'll take your second question
first and that is have we abandoned uh
the
possibility of working with the
companies that have
uh proven technologies uh and we have
two the bioentech pfizer and the modern
vaccines
no we have not and we would very much
welcome a partnership with them because
as we were describing you know the
development from scratch of a vaccine
does take time and while african has in
a very short period of time working with
the academics in south africa been able
to develop an mrna vaccine construct
based on publicly available information
this is a new construct and therefore it
will have to go through the entire
clinical development
program
starting with animal studies and then go
through clinical trials which means that
it's not going to be really available
as a vaccine
that before the end of 23 or more likely
2024
this can be this timeline can obviously
be shortened considerably
if
a known technology or known vaccine with
proven efficacy and safety were to
transfer their know-how and tech and and
technical uh provide technical
assistance to the hub and to the spokes
which means it's just a question of
really producing that vaccine at the
quality standards and i think we've
the south african have been shown that
it's possible to do it so i think it's a
myth that low and middle-income
countries cannot produce mrna vaccines
we know now from the landscaping we've
done that there are several existing
sites around the world that are quite
capable of producing these vaccines so
yes i think the who is very open and
committed to working with partners there
are a number of other
companies mostly biotech companies
smaller companies again from around the
world that have